die die da vom himmel schwebt könnte die
geschichte kenias neu spalten zum ersten
mal kandidiert in dem ostafrikanischen
land eine frau als vize-präsidentin in
diesen tagen hätte smarter car uhr von
einem termin zum nächsten die 64-jährige
weiß wie hoch die erwartungen vor allem
der frauen an sie sind ich denke dies
ist ein höhepunkt nicht nur meine
persönlichen reise sondern unserer
kollektiven reise als frauen die darum
kämpfen einen platz am tisch zu bekommen
und dieses mal haben wir einen platz im
höchsten amt in der präsidentschaft
die nominierung von mothercare uhr als
seine vize war ein kuh von altpolitiker
raila odinga zum fünften mal bewirbt
sich der 77-jährige um das höchste amt
im staate noch immer spielen in kenia
die volksgruppen bei wahlen eine
entscheidende rolle massa carrara gehört
zur größten kikuyu auf der wählerstimmen
käding damen zählen
sie ist die beste prinzipientreu erste
frau die wir je hatten deshalb menge sie
die eiserne lady und deshalb lieben wir
sie so meine stimme geht an x factor und
raila odinga
eine frau zu ermutigen heißt die ganze
nation zu stärken und ich glaube dass
die frauen und das ganze land stärkt
die 64 jährige carola ist eine top
juristin mit schwerpunkt auf
frauenrechten sie war einst
justizministerin gilt als integer und
nicht korrupt in einem land dessen
politiker sich oft selbst bereichern
eine ausnahme
wenn ihr seht dass jemand geld von der
regierung gestohlen hat solltet ihr
wissen dass er euer essen gegessen hat
euren job weggenommen hat euro medizin
genommen hat unter wasser getrunken hat
wenige tage vor der wahl ist die angst
groß dass es wie 2007 zu massenunruhen
und toten kommen könnte das wieder
konkurrierende volksgruppen
gegeneinander kämpfen frauen könnten als
wählerinnen eine entscheidende rolle
spielen doch nicht nur dort noch nie
haben sich so viele frauen für
spitzenämter im ganzen land beworben
auch josephine julia will es wissen die
38 jährige kandidiert im bezirk samburu
um einen für frauen bestimmten sitz in
der nationalversammlung
als kind entging sie nur knapp einer
genitalverstümmelung
seitdem kämpft sie dagegen und auch
gegen kinder und zwangsheirat
die frauen hier haben es sehr schwer
weil sie nicht einmal die chance haben
zur schule zu gehen ich habe das gefühl
sie können nicht mithalten
sie müssen früh heiraten aber die
anderen die es geschafft haben uns ein
paar von ihnen können das schaffen
müssen wir ein amt kandidieren weil so
viele andere entmutigt sind so sehr
josephine cool er von einer besseren
gesellschaft träumt so wenig kann sie an
der politischen realität vorbei ohne
geld keine macht das ist gängige praxis
in kenia ihren wahlkampf besuchern zahlt
sie umgerechnet 80 cent sonst würden sie
vermutlich nicht kommen ihr solltet mich
wählen
morgen kassieren sie vielleicht beim
politischen gegner
julia ist eine samburu eine volksgruppe
in der die männer dominieren das
politische engagement einer frau ist
hier eine absolute ausnahme junge männer
unterstützen sie doch ältere bedrohen
sie auch mit dem tod und trotzdem
kandidiert sieht ich habe mich
entschlossen zu kandidieren weil ich
veränderungen sehen möchte und ich hoffe
dass es so weit gut wird es ist positiv
und ich freue mich darauf unser ziel zu
erreichen und sicherzustellen dass wir
das schaffen
charity kasami cecconi gehört bereits 22
prozent weiblicher abgeordneter
eigentlich müssten es nach kenia us
verfassung mindestens ein drittel sein
charity bewirbt sich für die partei des
jetzigen vize-präsidenten william ruto
seit fünf jahren schon vertritt sie
ihren bezirken djourou im westen kenias
im parlament die 44 jährige weiß wie
hart das politikgeschäft für frauen ist
ich arbeite wirklich besonders hart das
liegt an der kultur in afrika an der
kultur in kiel frauen haben viele
herausforderungen durchlebt wenn wir
also in eine position kommen wollen wir
ein vorbild sein wir wollen dass die
menschen etwas von unserer führung
lernen
charity reist unermüdlich durch ihren
wahlkreis sie gehört zur volksgruppe der
heute eröffnet sie in einer grundschule
neue klassenräume die vierfache mutter
glaubt fest daran dass bildung für
mädchen der schlüssel zu gleichen
chancen ist umgerechnet 800 1000 euro
bekommt sie wie alle abgeordneten pro
jahr für ihren bezirk treibt damit
entwicklungsprojekte voran trotzdem muss
sie immer wieder erleben wie männliche
widersacher sie niedermachen in kenia
haben die männer nicht akzeptiert dass
frauen mit ihnen konkurrieren sollten es
gibt auch die schlechte kultur dass
männer uns als bedrohung sehen dass sie
uns als nicht würdig für diese position
ansehen
politische teilhabe an der macht und
mehr mitsprache darum geht es den vielen
frauen die sich für politische ämter
bewerben und die kämpfen hart dafür
damit sich für alle frauen in kenia
etwas ändert matador hat auch die
begeistert die nicht politisch mit ihr
sympathisieren die chance das klima mit
der 64 jährigen einen wichtigen schritt
in sachen gleichberechtigung macht ist
groß einen schritt bei dem die eiserne
lady die männer mitnehmen will alle
themen sind weiblich und männlich
zugleich aber sie werden am ende allen
helfen
fast 60 jahre lang ist kenia nun
unabhängig so lange hat es gedauert bis
eine frau nach dem zweithöchsten amt
greifen darf sie habe mit ihrer
kandidatur schon einen unterschied
gemacht sagt massa carrara und sie wolle
das erst recht in ihrer neuen funktion
tun
[Musik]